hey guys how's it going so if you're if
you're new here I'm just saying this is
my kitchen and we are doing a Halloween
special and this is going to be probably
one of the most difficult things well at
least it looks pretty difficult I'm
gonna try to make cake pops you guys
have been requesting this I think
probably for at least four or five years
since I ever first started making
cooking videos so we're gonna make these
super cool candy eye pops as first you
have to make a cake and that is
something that I can handle of course
we're gonna use a blender so for our
cake we're gonna need the cake mix cake
mix in oh gosh I freaking love cake so
much and goes our 1 cup of water 1/2 cup
vegetable oil 1/2 cup
look at me I'm measuring I'm all I'm all
grown up and you go 3 eggs 1 2 3 3 pull
huevos keep on those okay boy now we're
gonna mix this up oh wait don't be none
of that they'll be none of that
get a dog they said I love my dog
keep one here you don't idiot and we're
gonna go on 3 2 1 we have liftoff cake
in the blender baby
this is how we this is how we do it
I think that's good we've got our
already greased pan now you just take
this and you just dump it in there look
at this
all we have to do is put this in the
oven cook this for 33 minutes we go and
now we bake I'll see you guys in however
many minutes it takes piece we are back
with the cake pops so to make cake pops
this is pretty interesting you basically
take a bunch of cake throw it in a bowl
add a container of frosting mix it up
real good real nice make balls shove a
stick in it shove it into the chocolate
melter and that's it we're gonna start
with a cake so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna take this cake we're gonna
put the whole cake in here just like so
okay so this thing's pretty cool it
melts chocolate so basically all you got
to do is turn it on and we put chocolate
in it we're gonna put those in here hey
like so that's a lot cool it's open up
our frosting we're gonna just put this
all in here like so because we need to
mix it up it says use the whole
container so we're gonna use the whole
container
[Music]
now we're gonna get in real good and
just mash this up you can you can use
really any method that you want but I
feel like in my small feeble mind this
to me looks like the best idea cupcakes
are done Francesca I may need your help
because I'm I'm in a little trouble I'm
in a little bit of a pickle I always get
yelled at for not pulling my hair up
when I cook but I'm cooking for myself
this isn't a restaurant this is this is
this is Justine's kitchen if you want
food this is not where you're gonna go
for to get to get a meal
let me tell you that how is this
supposed to go into a ball just like
that spray me up girl
oh god I'm grease stop light a little
piglet look at this
that's a ball ready watch I wonder what
this tastes like
what is it good it's like it's like
already chewed up cake like you don't
even have to do the work we're gonna
work on these get these nice and melted
up something that I learned from my dear
friend row on nerdy nummies you guys
will see this in a future video like
future future
she caught me that you use these little
crystal things it's basically like oil
crystals and it gives you an not go up
I'll help you up gives you a nice
dipping consistency makes it nice and
oily okay good good for you good for you
chocolate
this isn't chocolate it's not chocolate
it's candy you can't call something
chocolate the plot chocolate I've
learned so much Monroe
then dip dip dip stick you want to
expedite and I like it yeah let's just
stick these in
thank you
perfect fit so we're gonna let those
freeze I'm gonna let this this chocolate
that's not chocolate melt up nicely and
we'll be back here in probably two
seconds because this is Joey Benedict
now the time has come we've taken these
delicious pops out of the fridge freezer
wherever the heck they were and we're
gonna dip them so good we're gonna dip
them so good is what we're gonna do
you're just gonna dip this in like so
I'm gonna give it a little skin scoot
scoot scoot scoot scoot scoot
okay here we go we got one ball I'm
gonna stick it here just in and then
we're gonna take one of these little
blue candies we're gonna shove it right
on the front I'm not sure if my eyeball
proportions are correct I also got these
little candy eyes to make things easier
she can dip that in a little chocolate
just set it there yeah I wouldn't
recommend if you have some sort of
Halloween party like I wouldn't
recommend making them exactly like I did
them because they look terrible
I think you can do better don't you let
your amazing eye cakepops cool well
whatever they did they the candy just
kind of melted and formed around them
you're gonna get an edible marker this
is something that you can eat it's
called a food writer and you're gonna
just illustrate some veins to make it
super creepy and super spooky the
spookiest whole day of them all oh boy
and here they are our amazing eyeball
cake pops I'll put a link in the
description where you guys can find out
how to make these and I'm almost 100%
confident that yours will probably look
better than mine thank you guys so much
for watching I will see you in
tomorrow's video where we will be making
something extra extra spooky it probably
won't be that spooky at all but who
knows till then see you guys later
[Music]
this just looks horrible
I thought next time you invite me over
you have better utensils and better
icing that looks so stupid
I can tell us to see you too good call
but oh here we go good way button what's
that I just drop yeah so for this one